on l'applaudît samedi bonjour tu l'as
fait une grosse bise
comment tu le trouve bon m'arrivait
l'équipe j'ai déjà amoureuse de lui
il ya longtemps
depuis combien de temps bien heureuse de
pierre bachelet tu as écrit d'amour il
n'a jamais répondu
or quand même tu exagères 1 quand même
je veux te voir avec avec avec sens tout
à l'heure se repentent un an et demi
maintenant vous avez fait connaissance
et voilà weepu tu attends quand tu peux
avoir la patience d'attendre attendre
qu'est ce que tu me chanter samedi pour
toi lamoureux a compris ce que ça veut
dire
il doit me dis moi demain
je ne
beauté
oui
est-ce que tu mises en chantier avec ton
amoureux pas tout de suite il faut
attendre quelques années